the cost of crap friends can be
expensive just like the cost of inviting
the wrong woman into your life if you're
not attentive to the guys that you hang
out with they will drag you down the
types of guys that you're going to run
into out there they're always a lot of
fun you're going to meet them in your
younger years and drink with them you
know you party with them sort of thing
you know you go out and pick up girls
together they're like my brother from
another mother but if you're not
attentive to the sort of character that
they have and you look past negative
traits like I had a friend that he would
tell me stories proudly how you know he
would go over to his friend's place or
his mom you know would be around and he
would bang his friend's mom there's got
to be some sort of moral compass or
boundary when it comes to dudes when you
invite them into your life you want a
guy that you can trust you got to size
people up you got to get good at sizing
people up you will be betrayed by women
in your life and you will be betrayed by
friends if you let it happen you're very
good friends your absolute best friends
will talk to your face but every
single time you guys are apart he's
always got your back